we're all set for an amazing Universal
Studios Adventure I'm pretty good proud
of myself fun ride yes we can go on the
right now when we can
good morning everybody it is
6.09.
we just came back from our awesome New
York trip and uh had one day in between
and now we're heading to Universal
Studios Florida and Disney World for
seven more days of fun
let's go
[Music]
we're in the lounge hit the Customs
now we're getting on the plane right
let's go
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
almost three hours on the plane now
we're officially in a hot City right now
we need to go get the car
get comfy and head to our Airbnb
swim
[Music]
all right got the car key now we're
heading to the car
let's go
this is our car
for the next eight days
we are two hours early so we can't
really go into our Airbnb so what we're
gonna do we're gonna pick up some lunch
because
kids are very hungry what are they
all right we spent like we spent an hour
in Chipotle because we have two hours to
kill so hello yeah we finished the lunch
was pretty good yeah I share with
Catherine I couldn't finish it yeah so
we're sure and now we're gonna go to um
public to get some water
for the week all right we got into our
Airbnb let me give you a tour it's a
very nice two-floor house so when you're
walking from the front door Michael hey
so there's a bathroom
[Music]
here with the shower
and then there's a king-sized bedroom we
got a one extra room and then walk over
here it's the dining room
living room
and the kitchen we want to get groceries
and then here Catherine she's swimming
in the backyard it's nice to have a pool
and heading up to upstairs
hello
and then there's another king size
master bedroom
and then over on this side
there's a laundry
and then go to this room this is
Catherine's room there's like a bunk bed
with a trundle this can sleep a lot of
people say you can sleep two up there
two here and then another two here
[Music]
the boys room the boys are watching TV
this is a Harry Potter thing
[Music]
it has
this I don't know what you call it those
things the broomsticks I like this box
too and in Harry Potter whatever this uh
vintage tables
and in the bathroom here for the kids to
use
yep that's it all right last night what
did we do Evan I plan the next two days
at Universal and a little bit of Disney
the kids went swimming and chilled Mina
did some vlogging and I and and she did
some cooking and preparation and I did
some planning so now hopefully we're all
set for an amazing Universal Studios
Adventure
we are ready to go to Universal Studios
the kids have some breakfast did you eat
the toast and the breakfast
yeah so yeah okay kids have breakfast I
have one egg I fell on the floor
oh I washed it okay I'm not gonna five
seconds yeah not about five seconds
three seconds okay
so we're gonna head to Universal Studios
we will oh I'm in this hey everybody
I'm gonna try to Vlog it they won't
allow anything carry on like no bags so
I'm gonna try my best to Vlog it and
then not lose my phone we believe in you
Nina
[Music]
all right we have arrived we just parked
Cat in the Hat so six six zero
[Music]
all right officially made it end now
we're going to Manning black ride Evan
and Jeffrey are going to
compete who's the best shooter ever what
about me
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
so next ride is Transformers are you
gonna transform Catherine no uh no okay
well I'm just going to my god mode yeah
sure all right let's go
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all right the Transformers Rye was fun
they were screaming in the back I was
screaming too screaming at the back I
was like why are you screaming all I see
is a head in front of me a head in front
of me I don't really see the 3D thingy
maybe your glasses are broken yeah maybe
my glasses was not working properly but
anyhow they had a lot of fun I had a lot
I heard a lot of screams we kept dodging
something whoa
anyway so next one we're gonna go to
fast ferries Fast and Furious
[Music]
all right we had a great time sitting in
the car waiting they actually it was um
the cart was broke down so we can't
really go we literally just started and
then um the car the ride stopped working
and then we sat in there for half an
hour and then they they escort our ass
out
all right let's go fun ride yeah we can
go on the right now when we can
we're gonna eat at this restaurant very
famous there's a big lineup I'm gonna
get fish and chips Jeffrey's gonna get
fish and chips what are you getting
no Hayden's getting fish and chips
jiffy's getting bangers and mash
her and I were gonna share something
Jeffrey lunch looks really good how's
the fish and chips Hayden so good yeah
amazing
next rise to the Harry Potter we got the
fast pass because we got stopped at the
Fast and Furious ride
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we are off to somewhere there
[Music]
the boys are done with the Simpson Rye
we basically just waited watched one
sure and then wait it now we're going to
the born show
the show was actually really good Evan
do you like it
yeah well done do you guys enjoy yeah
yeah you enjoy good let's go
all right next stop we're gonna get some
ice cream
[Music]
all right it's day one of the um
Universal Studio and the book we're
gonna go head home relax and have dinner
all right we got home chill a little bit
showered kids kissed they had a shower
and we have pizza for dinner
and then Jeffrey's doing uh dishes I was
gonna say do laundry no he's doing
dishes
and now we're gonna we're gonna watch
some TV show me
stranger things
and then we're gonna go to bed and have
a
great day tomorrow we have to wake up we
have to wake up early again tomorrow we
have to wake up at seven and then be at
the park at eight o'clock no we leave at
eight o'clock be at the park at nine
before nine and then hopefully tomorrow
if we get a coffee
she never got a coffee I had an iced
coffee but it wasn't it was it was just
okay yeah she needs hot coffee do you
want to see what we do on day two at
Orlando
Universal this video right there next to
us go click it continue to believe we'll
see you there